for over a century london has been
marking buildings where historic figures
lived with a blue plaque earlier this
month the lives of two remarkable
americans william and ellen kraft were
commemorated by the city the craft's
incredible story and their escape from
slavery is part of a change in how
london remembers its past mts taeyab
went to meet their descendants to hear
more
across london on some of its finest
streets are elegant blue plaques
commemorating prominent figures from the
past who have stayed lived or worked in
buildings around the british capital
those honored range from wartime prime
minister winston churchill to legendary
filmmaker alfred hitchcock the names on
the blue plaques are a very good measure
of whatever the society at the time
thinks is important
anna evas is a director at english
heritage the charity which has been
responsible for placing the plaques
around london for the past 135 years
when i first became responsible for the
scheme two things struck me like there
there wasn't a huge number to um
non-white people
and we were getting no nominations at
all for non-white people so both of
those things seemed to me to be
something we needed to tackle
of the more than
1160 notable people who are name checked
on the plaques 96 percent are white
while only 4 percent have been from
black asian or minority ethnic
backgrounds something english heritage
says it's working hard to change given
london's ancient and current history of
migration as well as britain's colonial
past
i was very excited when i found out
about it american julia ellen kraft
davis is a direct descendant of the
latest figures to be immortalized with a
blue plaque outside this modest house in
west london
her great great grandparents william and
ellen kraft
the crafts had been slaves in georgia
before escaping to britain in 1850 where
they became prominent abolitionists but
it's how they escaped which to this day
continues to amaze the fair-skinned
ellen posed as a disabled white man and
william as his servant
what did it feel like when you first saw
that blue plaque and saw their names
well it was
it was special i was really
thankful
davis says the craft's story which also
saw them learn how to read and write
become teachers publish a widely
acclaimed book called running a thousand
miles for freedom and purchasing their
own home
needs to be remembered our young people
need to see this because this is how
they
consider you know the class went through
a lot to be to be free
and so that this is to help the young
people understand it may not be easy you
may not have a lot of money
but you know you still need to go ahead
and do the best you can
the crafts had several children before
moving back to the u.s after the 13th
amendment abolishing slavery was
ratified but some of their descendants
still live in britain your dna my dna
like davis cousin chris clark who along
with other family members attended the
unveiling of the blue plaque together
what does it feel like to have this
history
here in the uk so far away from me isn't
that something
william and ellen kraft figures from the
past whose names won't soon be forgotten
for cbs saturday morning empty house
tayyip london
i love those plaques when you walk
around and you see those and it's nice
to see now you start having to pay
attention to other people that you
didn't know before yeah and i never
realized she posed as a disabled
man and and he and her husband were used
as servants because she was so fair she
could pass in shameless promotion here i
have a piece on sunday morning tomorrow
on the subject of passing so be sure to
watch this